[Music]
thank you well good morning everybody my
name is simple um I hope to direct the
joint Harvard MIT program on ethics and
governance in AI and formally used to
run public policy for AI for Google and
really excited for the panel that we
have this morning so let me observe that
this is probably the third or fourth
panel we are doing on governance or
issues and so I want to use this
opportunity to kind of move us in a
slightly different direction and - I
guess follow Max's exhortation this
morning to move us in a more
crystallized concrete direction where
does this all come - what have we really
been doing for the last few days and so
let me begin by observing that for such
a sort of world-changing technology our
recommendations from a law and
regulation standpoint are fairly
milquetoast right you look at the list
of things that we have here um they're
not really things that really require
actually perhaps a whole lot of law and
regulation as sort of formally stated
and in fact reading a lot of the reports
in you know sort of policy and
regulation around AI you know they tend
to follow a similar pattern first
there's a lot of throat-clearing there's
a lot of risks and opportunities from AI
and then they tend to conclude on
something I call sort of like the magic
theory of dialogue right so from a law
and regulatory dimension it's something
along the lines of well we just need to
get people together to discuss and you
know the results will be great right and
then the paper sort of abruptly ends and
I want to see if we can get ourselves a
little bit further than that right to
get really much more concrete about from
a law and regulatory standpoint you know
what can we do what can we actually
introduce here is there a role for these
two sort of levers on shaping the kind
of future of the technology and so Nico
let me start with you actually so I know
your work at the future society is very
much in this vein right which is we need
more dialogue in the law and regulatory
space around AI but let me ask you
really concretely like where where are
we all going where what what sorts of
law and regulation you know is the
future society pointed towards but in
general you know what would you hope
that you know lawyers and policymakers
should really kind of be headed towards
well thanks for the question I think
it's a very important question yeah like
much is I never okay and I can respond
by talking to you about very practical
stuff that we're working on right now
aligned with that the very first one is
something that Cyrus works and advise
the UE State Minister for a I mentioned
yesterday and we're actively preparing
for is a well curated collective
intelligence methodologies induced by a
platform for global dialogue it's the
global governance of AI roundtable ggr
and if I can interrupt what
methodologies are you talking about
specifically something along the lines
of you know you know we think everybody
should consult with the public before
deploying an AI system or so we are
boring from the latest collective
intelligence methodologies for example
we are refraining from doing any panels
any keynotes
it's only breakout sessions which are
curated and prepared month in advance
right now we are in the preparation
cycle we have hand-picked a number of
experts a number of practitioners
investors doers industrialists from the
five continents relevant to the to the
to the topic partnering with
organizations such as OECD UNESCO I
Triple E cxi World Bank to try and bring
the right kind of conversation there so
the goal is still very much in the
conversation vein yeah but it's not only
speaking in the year we have identified
will with those partners 14 different
topics and prepare the conversation so
that on the day of the conference the
collective intentions exercise can lead
to somewhere that's the first very
active process and it's not a conference
it's a multilateral multi-stakeholder
dialogue process by no means it's
perfect it's totally imperfect of course
it's always an experiment but that's
something that it's going to be the
second edition of and we're actively
working on the second thing I only allow
you a second one so yeah but the second
thing I want to mention is this AI for
SDG Center that we have been working on
with the UAE government with the UN
agencies for over two years now and
we're envisioning this very much aligned
with the proposal up there as
public private people partnership
factory out of which we can gather and
engineer the business models the ethical
models the legal models the the it said
IPR and without more this so let me
right there actually cuz I think that
actually sets up the discussion in a
really good way and Wendell if I can
bring you in I mean I know you weren't
you are an old hand at these kinds of
discussions and I think in particular
what you have to offer this discussion
is your experience in the bioethics
space and I'm curious you know is this
kind of the state of discussion you
would expect at this moment in AI or do
you think we should be you know reaching
further right then then kind of these
types of efforts so as many of you
already know I've taken responsibility
is to lead to to develop an
International Congress for the
governance for the AI and perhaps
differs a little bit from what Niko has
just talked about in that that there is
some pressure to go beyond even the
conversations and put in place some new
mechanisms for the oversight and
coordination of developments and
artificial intelligence and that's also
a similar concern in the biotechnology
space for various reasons we are
starting with artificial intelligence
rather than synthetic biology but the
idea here is to put in place mechanisms
that hopefully would translate to other
emerging technologies they all have very
similar problems within the governance
you must speak a little bit to the kind
of accountability measures that you
would perceive right like do you want
like a Council of nonprofits that will
be able to subpoena companies for
instance or not at this stage okay it
but excuse me it's clear at this stage
there is a wide variety of institutions
that are jumping in and will take on
various governance tasks so at this
stage our first concern is coordination
and cooperation and agile and collective
oversight flagging the gaps that need to
be addressed and if there are gaps that
need to be addressed then it's not just
with
they get addressed governmentally but
whether they can be addressed through
soft governance meaning standards and
laboratory practices and procedures
insurance policies whether they can be
addressed through corporate oversight or
whether they can be addressed through
technological solutions so all of that
comes into play this is largely about
how we can look at this comprehensively
and whether we can put in place a
good-faith broker to bring all the
stakeholders together which means not
only government but also means the
research laboratories and let me pause
you there because I think that sets up
the scene really in a nice way and is
maybe a good way to bring in Jeff and
Helen at this discussion so I think
we've heard a very hopeful story from
the last two panelists you know there's
a these big efforts that kind of bring
governance and discussion together
there's lots of different institutions
taking on different tasks of governance
but I think you know for the
institutions that both of you are part
of right at ten cents and FHI you know
you're participants in a lot of these
forums and maybe to put a provocative
point on it you know is this kind of
patchwork this quilt of different
regulatory and governance
you know approaches is it working like
what do you think is missing in the
space or are you pretty happy with the
state of affairs thank you is it's good
to be here to take this the conference I
think maybe the air can bring many
benefits to our society the Supreme
Court can see 90% of humans in the rules
and the medical services mayor can bet
can to Patriot economic diagnosis for
the patients and also these benefits the
AMA bring many risks to our society and
as a traditional regulatory and
legislations is is not sufficient to
handle the risk brought by air so I
think there will be three levels of
legislation for us to write and a finer
point on it so you're saying that we
actually aren't where we need to be
right now yeah yeah I think there will
be three levels of regulations the first
level is a lot of Essex ooh today area
is talking about Essex and making some
statements about
the beneficial air the inclusive air
democratizing air and air for good yeah
every person organization maybe many
nations are making make making this cut
and still stay that means expect that
we're sorry' finish that there's to a
lack of international agreement how
because yeah is very a big thing the
impact of humanities in the universe so
I think a wave with to lack of
international consensus are how they
will approach so yeah right but you
think that things like fairness should
eventually be enshrined in say
international law so you would say that
it's good for maybe all the countries
and different stakeholders to get
together and say we want this definition
of fairness to be the one that all
companies should follow a single way we
asked in the early stage and a single
maybe first we all call about a
collaboration at a corporation within
nations between companies I think so we
can we can we can try to propose an
international conference agreement maybe
a treaty are a success of a.m. so the
area that will be represents those
opinions from other nations or
regardless you're a seekers or your
nationality
we will need a such a framework on yeah
so let me pause you there Helen do you
want to jump in I mean did you return to
the original issue I mean is the current
global system of governance around AI
working right now from your perspective
as a participant right and a lot of
these forums I guess I would say it
seems like it's not really existent yet
and like starting to emerge I also kind
of want to push back on you a little bit
actually bring it in that I mean this
conference has been very explicitly set
up as focusing on AGI and you I thought
it was interesting that you opened this
this panel which is sort of about
governance mm-hmm and you asked
specifically about laws and regulations
which are sort of the hard side of
governance as opposed to the soft side
and it actually feels to me like we're
basically not ready at all to have sort
of laws and regulations that relate to
AGI you know as far as I can tell and so
I think there are lots and lots of I
mean I'd be problem with talking about
anything in AI is that it's such a
gigantic space this
many different issues so many different
applications or identifying cops and
drone targeting right so I think it's
really good that the space has started
to sort of specialize a little bit some
compasses like this are being like hey
this is the set of issues we want to
talk about it's AGI we're not talking
about self-driving cars we're not
talking about drone targeting or
identifying cats so I think there are
lots of lots of different steps that
need to be taken on different sides of
this technology and I'm excited that
there are starting to be people
specializing in sort of various
applications and thinking about what the
regulations we need for those
applications would be I feel like for AG
I wrote a much more preliminary stage
anyway so Helen I think has put forth
actually quite provocative thesis I
think right which is to say if the
question of the panel is you know what
kinds of law and regulation do we want
around AGI your answer is none at the
moment right and that actually there's
maybe a good argument to say no right I
don't know if everybody on the panel
would agree with that though like as it
pertains to AGI with the other three
panelists agree with the notion that you
know there is actually no role for law
and regulation here and hard law and
regulations sorry to be clear anyone can
jump in okay yeah he could go ahead well
I really believe that the right kind of
governance of AGI will be baked out of
the right kind of governance for Ani and
whatever we do to pave the way in a
holistic manner from a research
perspective from a business model
perspective but also from a governance
perspective connecting and articulating
the very long - very short term is valid
and that's why we speak about governance
more than regulation because governance
the business of government of governance
is about enabling and constraining
striking and maintaining all the time
the right balance between constraining
and enabling and often time the notion
of laws and regulations point a bit too
much towards constraining so that's why
it's so I think it's very valid and it's
great that we're starting to discuss
today about the governance of AGI
because about planning it's about
projecting and we don't need to be
regulating to talk productively
fruitfully about governance mmm-hmm this
area okay when do you end up in yeah I
mean III I agree with both of you so far
I don't think there's
the room for law and regulation around
AGI at this point this is largely a
discussion among scholars and research
centers it may be that AGI concerns some
what will inform discussions about what
kinds of governance mechanisms
understanding I'm not using law and
regulation I'm using the governance
mechanism term should be put in place
but I think we often get a little naive
in this room and maybe a little overly
idealistic about the trajectory for AGI
and what AGI will bring about without
really seriously looking at what's
happening between here and there and the
governance and governmental responses to
that that are going to shape it so for
example with the SDGs and within the UN
they understand that emerging
technologies will help in the
realization of all 17 of the sustainable
development goals but at this moment
there is deep concern that the emerging
technologies and particularly AI will
upset the realization of some of these
goals particularly when we talked about
jobs we all understand that territory
but also in the way in which AI is
exacerbating inequality and how that's
leading to instability and how that
contributes to to food insecurity and
and shelter and a whole flock of other
issues so the first thing you are going
to see is responses coming out of the
international community about ways in
which in the short term in the more
immediate term we can address the
imbalances that are leading to death
stabilization within within the world
yeah and just let me let me just add one
other pointer the other is I think none
of us are naive about the fact that
there are forces in this world that are
more interested in instability and
competition than they are in coop we're
about to get to some of that so right so
the key point here is the project I'm
involved in right
is not particularly concerned with AGI
and I'm not going to pretend pretend
that it is but what does it have to do
with AGI it has to do with whether we
can create a culture of cooperation
around the development of API
cooperation internationally cooperation
is a habit it sometimes has to start
with working on shared concerns and then
progress toward more difficult issues
okay I gotta go one step right but the
problem we have at the moment is one of
the most difficult issues artificial
Lethal lethal weapon systems they are
forced they have been forced to the
fourth at the very beginning and they
embody the insecurities and the
competitive instincts of that now
exhausted by tensions between nations
okay so Jeff I want to get you to have a
final word here before I kind of pivot
us a little bit so I'm curious if you
have a response to the last few comments
which is I guess provoked by Helens kind
of resistance to the way I framed up
this panel which is to say no one's
really doing anything real on hard law
and policy and then you and then I think
the panel has you know steadfastly
stated okay well we're not about lon
hard law and policy right now what we
really need is dialogue what we really
need is governance do you do you buy
that that I think there are lots of okay
partially yeah possibly
can I get a disagreement yeah AJ is too
far away there's no such thing and AJ
are so we cannot regulate as I seen that
it does not exist enough the yeah is all
user in some specific domains Intel
partition in micro service in finance so
there are many already many lost their
accounts from our world are trying to
make new regulations about this kind of
air regulations but not for the idea
mm-hmm asking ways to how is there still
room for we can we can make regulations
for the AGI in future maybe maybe we can
make make has some predictions what kind
of a gel do once in the future mmm-hmm
yeah maybe if the idea is embodied that
you know robot can we have a marriage or
relationship with the AJ that
kind of future stuff I think we can sink
nah
great yeah Nico you are a jumper I will
give you I will give you a tweet length
response all Twitter 140 characters yes
so as part of the OECD high-level expert
group on AI governance one way we're
trying to bake long term into short term
is to bring a principle of risk
management into the framework that's so
where we're trying not to talk about AGI
and let plan and yet plant a seed
because these guidelines could become
something that could become a global
influential that's right just one tiny
example of how we're trying and it's
imperfect to articulate the long and the
short term yeah great so let me concede
you've defeated me right we've all
agreed sort of that we want to do
governance but let me pivot us slightly
and recognize a certain reality about
the way in which AI is developed and
deployed which is to say that you know
frankly actually a lot of the AI that is
developed and deployed and the most
important systems that are being
deployed right now are in the hands of a
relatively small number of companies
right and so the nihilist or the cynic
in me would say well this is all very
nice that what you're doing with the
OECD it's all very nice what you're
doing having these nice meetings in
different places but you know what is
your actual point of leverage over these
companies right and that's particularly
in a world where I think some people
have made the argument that you know the
the global system of rules is sort of
breaking down right and so let me put
that challenge to the panel and say okay
well I think we all agree that we should
work on governance right what will make
that government's effective in a world
where really a small number of corporate
interests actually have a really
dominant role and it is sort of at their
election that they would adopt some of
these rules anyone want pick that up
yeah I can strongly contest okay the
fact that you're neglecting the
importance of governments in long term
techno scientific revolutions Facebook
Google Ober did not invent any science I
mean not as exchanging but for a long
term they innovated on top of massively
publicly funded research I agree which
gives you a lot of hope and that's why
you're staying inside
I'm gonna be calling on you later so be
ready it doesn't need a lot of hope
because we the people as citizens have a
lot more agency that we think over the
long term that that's but by agree with
you it's changing and I agree with your
agency's transferring and that's why I
really want this CERN for AI project to
focus on science so as to bring to swing
back the pendulum of research away from
industry back into academia okay right
right so right so the the the you're not
necessarily putting forward a theory
that we're gonna guilt-trip the
companies into you know working with
civil society but instead you're saying
that there is a big role for sort of
public funding to play to change the
balance of power today and tomorrow okay
any other comments on this yeah I mean I
have a comment and I think that comment
is more about the moment in history that
we're at and that we we acknowledge it
that's true we don't get carried away
with our elitist position in this whole
conversation and recognize that the
world is at an inflection point and it's
not just an an affliction point because
of Technology it's an inflection point
because rightly or wrongly large numbers
of people in the world are perceiving
that this international order of
cooperation and domination by
multinational corporations and the whole
kit and caboodle isn't really working
for them and therefore they are willing
to apparently to bring down the whole
the whole international mechanism thing
that's if that's what what is necessary
so that's already put pressure on all of
us who support International Cooperation
but secondly it's created opportunities
for politicians who want to build on
that and one of the ways they may build
on that is to make the multinational
corporations scapegoats particularly the
particularly the IP oligopoly which will
be the AI oligopoly right I think we all
understand that so it's not just about
issues around social many media and
manipulation of voters it's really that
if the corporation's don't get this they
will have government's come down hard
and they will be blamed for
destabilization that takes place so if I
can articulate it as a strategy right
you're kind of saying look the companies
might not get it right so that public
opinion will increasingly turn against
them and civil society has a need to
kind of stoke those flames right to get
politicians to take more aggressive
action here at least some groups within
civil telling you look like you want to
jump in yeah I guess I just have a
slightly different take I think your
comments have made sense and being very
reasonable but I think I would have to
take this maybe a little bit more
similar to Tim's in terms of thinking
that there are probably a small number
of actors where if you can work with
those actors that might be a highly
leveraged way to kind of implement
governance mechanisms of various kinds
and actually I think probably
essentially for that reason of the list
of you know goals are not sorry not
goals list of ideas that we voted on I
think the one that I am tentatively most
excited about was this idea of a
windfall clause and I think one of the
very nice features of that that idea is
that you really don't need many people
to agree in advance to do that that's
the kind of thing where you could I
could definitely imagine a small number
of companies deciding that that was a
thing that they were going to sign on
and do you have a you have a theory of
how to get companies to adopt that right
is it is it moral suasion like it is for
the best benefit of the world that you
should do this or I think I mean I think
this comes back to something that came
up yesterday as well which is I think a
lot of actors in this space want to be
doing the right thing and they just also
had sort of other other interests in
other things going on so I would imagine
the sort of best mechanisms for that to
be largely I guess private conversations
with certain people and then perhaps
that backed up by trying to understand
how the employees of the company would
feel about that turn understand how some
of the other stakeholders involved with
the company because that would it would
very likely be positive right and so
then sort of combining those yeah I
think well that's very speculative right
that's what I think is interesting is
this kind of emerging two-prong strategy
where you sort of have Wendell like is
the hammer right he's the heavy he's
coming in and basically saying like
don't get this right right like society
is gonna take care of you and then at
the same time there's a need to kind of
invest in these private conversations
that say well you know like those guys
outside I'm not I don't know if I'm not
with them but you sure
misrepresented sure I've destroyed my
senses that we're both yeah not so we've
given expression two different
strategies back both of these have to be
I also I also think it's not necessarily
a new or unusual thing maybe the
structure of the actors is slightly
different but I think a lot of friends
of mine who are involved in sort of
political organizing in other ways often
talk about the inside game and the
outside game the inside game being sort
of having people who know people in the
relevant government structures or
whatever who have those one-on-one
relationships who are having an in-depth
conversation and then the outside game
being political movements you know large
numbers of people large amounts of
pressure and the combination of those
friends we know much more than I do
about things like you know civil rights
or suffragette movement things like that
think that that combination is powerful
yeah so now Jeff I know you are on the
research side but I acknowledge that
I've put you in a little bit of an
awkward situation here as in that you
are representing the only company on the
panel I don't know if you would like to
defer comment or actually we'd like to
jump in on it I think it is not
necessary a partisan father Campbell is
like Facebook to be in too big have
enough powers I think in the last verse
every 20 years these companies being big
as a result of competition they bring
many benefits to us starting motor harms
and risks mm-hmm I think people are
worried today because two reasons first
the these companies can have access to
to huge amount of dates this and a way
we as a individual user feeling about
our we do not have come to tower data
the ownership is a hot topic in this
kind of issue
mm-hmm this is the first one and the
second one is transparency this
completes Google and Facebook videos all
kinds a gorilla blackbox algorithm image
this is about us but we do not have the
necessary information to know what
happened and the reasons for that she
invited two issues is very important if
we think about the AI maybe the idea
also tweet the two issues the first
access to the idea so as an individual
we don't have access to the AI the
abilities and the idea and the first
thing that we lack the tress
Transparency retirement can I can I put
a harder point on that like do you feel
that the companies or if you only want
to speak to 10 cent 10 cent if it like
has an obligation to ensure transparency
and proper data use yeah I think as a
company you develop this kind of
technology and your handle is usually
pairs a response responsibility to
handle this kind data and the technology
more transparently other you may be some
people in China some researchers and for
transparency you have to disclose the
source code to the consumers but I think
this is not necessary seen many people
did not understand the technical staff
AVU
you discuss the source code to consumers
they can't understand so we Pro I think
the other alternative approach may be
reasonable you can pry the explanation
just like as a GDP are they have an
article about the right to X expand the
nation regarding the paper here yeah
because of a party well great so we
about 15 minutes left there's some hands
I think of people who want to ask
questions and so Julie Newmar sorry yeah
I think it's coming around really really
terrific so just I want to pick up on
the who own I think which I would reform
as who owns the AI and what was it built
on there hasn't been discussion about
the ownership sort of in the form of
intellectual property and I think trade
secret which is one of the the key
things we need to be rethinking which is
that we currently operate in a regime
where we take for granted that once it's
inside the company is developed inside
the company it's owned by the company
and they have the right to exclude
others from it one of the ways of
thinking about GDP are is its divide and
conquer it's a hunt you know billions of
people individually just click yes yes
yes
aggregate the data do the analysis and
then there's there's not a way of
gaining access to it so it's just a
question if you have thoughts on IP
trade secret and who owns yeah yeah yeah
IP is a really interesting dimension on
this because it's it's relevant to
near-term systems it's relevant to
long-term systems and it's also a case
of hard law right if you want to make
that crude distinction so what's the
panel thing should we should we be
making changes in IP law right now to
deal with AI systems near Antwon turn
it's a big question you should spend an
entire day on week on that but one thing
we we have a vision of is that as we're
shifting the focus of business model
away from ownership into usage I think
we can apply this kind of methodologies
to IP as well it's it's not so much
about ownership anymore as it is about
control and making sure that we engineer
the right control mechanisms over the
use and the second and third order
consequences of big data driven machine
or an eccentric AI system is something
that I've interested in and I I think
that if we are able to shift a bit the
focus towards a bit more towards control
we can move away from some of the most
toxic polarizing features especially in
the American system which is litigation
prone where we've been seen toxic toxic
dynamics where patents are being used
solely for the objective of let's say
enabling progress on one hand and would
you say this is actually tacking a
little bit away from your original
position right which was to say hey we
need discussion and governance but now
humor seems like to be taking up a
pretty aggressive position to say u.s.
IP policy is wrong we should find ways
of changing it yes but that it I think
it aligns quite perfectly what I said
before it's part of the dialogue and
because there are so many
extraterritorial impact of the US patent
legislation and because WIPO let's say
has been a failure has been a collective
failure force we need to really also
have a dialogue which involves the
public and the private and the people
into into engineering these new models
and their shift into the age of
algorithmic governance in my view opens
up avenues of collaboration and that's
why again I'm sorry to harp on that a
bit I really want to bring science back
at the center of it in knowledge
creation because of because of the
ethics
which is totally imperfect yeah but yet
is a good resort at this point in time
so yeah sure can I be grumpy and draft
you into this I'm gonna I'm gonna again
be sort of the cynic and say ha it's
very interesting I too would love to
rebalance the balance of power between
sort of public institutions and funding
research and these enormous corporations
but the money is just not there and the
public will isn't there do you agree
with that statement and if you want to
talk about your experience and in
fighting this exact battle that's a good
question but I was thinking about how
regulation on IP could help right so
there's been a move towards defensive
patterns in some companies and I think
this is moving in the right direction
which is is gonna help avoid a little
bit of the concentration of power that
you know is troublesome but but
ultimately as we approach AGI I think we
might want to think about regulating IP
about AI in such a way that those
contributions are really humanity's
contributions and and cannot be you know
exclusively owned by a particular entity
mmm so
oh yeah Helen go ahead I would just I
think it's interesting that there's kind
of a natural parallel between these
considerations around IP and trade
secrets and the not to harp on the same
thing the whole time the way the
windfall Clause idea uh-huh because like
a classic objection to weakening IP law
is it reduces the incentive for
innovation and you know and the same
thing as a classic objection to you know
taxing profits or things like this and
so I think it's interesting in this
situation where we think there might be
these massive imbalances or these
massive potential gains that these
opportunities come up where you can sort
of shift around these factors without
necessarily taking away the incentives
in the way that people would usually
object to so massive massive investment
in in academic research in AI which I
mean has increased quite a bit in the
last couple of years not just in Canada
now we have lots of countries doing this
I think is also a you know move in the
right direction to shift a bit of that
about yeah definitely other questions
let's do one over here and I will come
back
so yes over there should we be concerned
that a windfall Clause will weaken
signals we receive in financial markets
so for example if the financial markets
think one in a thousand chance deepmind
works out that's not going to have as
big effect on Google's stock if we think
Google's going to limit their take to a
trillion dollars but if we think Google
could take a thousand trillion it will
have a massive effect on Google so we'll
gain a lot less information if we
credibly believe if we believe with
losses you've been the one who's been I
don't know I'm kind of skeptical that
financial markets are our best source of
information about progress in this area
Alan I see Alan raising his hand it's
his idea or like his joint idea I would
love to hear his point yeah and this is
a little bit inside baseball so I don't
want a rat hole on this issue so I mean
Alan if you want to jump in yeah half a
tweet if the financial market signal is
important to you you can set up a
contract for getting the windfall and
see how much of prices in the market
that's all thank you next question back
there please oh we have to yeah we'll do
both of them so those will be the last
two questions so whatever order you want
to do them in okay you've got the mic so
go ahead thanks panel
I think Martina Koons made a really good
point about the fact that AI is already
being regulated all around the world in
ways that none of us have any idea about
like in the civil aviation industry in
very specific industries there are
substantive hard laws being made that
will affect the development and
deployment of AI in really wide ranging
sectors and I was wondering what you
think we can do to sort of aggregate the
trajectories of law that are being made
in all of these individual patchwork
places in to like try to see where
they're going what effect they will have
a I and then a GI regulation and how we
can direct that progress through this
piecemeal system that we have right now
yeah I think that's actually really
intriguing that it strikes me and your
question raises this is that there's
this interesting break right which is
like if you look at near-term AI systems
the political reality is essentially
it's being regulated on a very much sort
of domain by domain or you know kind of
piecemeal way but when it comes to AGI
there's sort of this presumption that
like okay this is gonna be the thing
that we're gonna have to regulate right
and and yeah I'm interested in kind of
how you would respond to that right like
how do we transition from a world in
which the regulatory framework is in
crack in fact incredibly fragmented to a
world where it sounds like the
presumption of this discussion so far
has been like AGI will be a thing that
will have to be you know regulated as a
separate thing on its own I don't any
responses to that well I think the way
so much of the conversation here has
been has been caught between the world
as it is in the government structures we
have and the sense that we need more
agility we need it to be less top-down
we you know we need better distribution
mechanisms we already have a
distribution crisis we may need more
coordination and I think some of us what
we're talking about is how we bring in
new mechanisms that allow us slowly to
transition to more agile governance now
how quickly that will come where that we
will succeed or not none of us have
total control over that yeah but that's
certainly what's at the heart of the
proposal that that I'm engaged in
there's been so much talk about the need
for agile governance particularly when
we're talking about emerging
technologies but there's been very
little attempt to put the mechanisms in
place and begin to what we can do now
and slowly see if that gets enough mum
gets enough force behind it that we can
deal with some of these more tricky
policy issues you go you end up better
yep I think that we need to be very
cognizant of the fact that the air
revolution is not happening in a vacuum
and that it's part and it's at the core
it's a manifestation of the digital
revolution and so long as the current
paradigm of AI being big data-driven
machine learning centric a system which
could change the data governance remains
the the highest point of leverage to
create and to move beyond fragmentation
that that's why the Europeans in the
room I've had a particular interested in
looking how gdpr
creates the conditions for you know a
level playing field across several
layers several layers of AI governance
that's but but let me say that the point
that you're raising and the demand
you're putting is is very valid and very
needed and one context that we have
particularly interesting to articulate
that that conversation is developing
world and developing economies I think
particularly in those contexts there is
a need for policy play box because the
the digital divide in the age of AI will
will will grow in cost potentially
exponentially maybe not exponentially
but the curve is steep and it's
worrisome and is it the position of the
future society that the GDP are norm
should apply to all emerging economies
no okay
but do we discussed yep to be discussed
I see we have another question you've
been waiting sir yes go ahead
yes well my point is about that we
should not we cannot put on our
shoulders all the effort of the science
of AGI meaning that pulling into the key
academia more of the research will also
involve other partners such as you know
the sociologists the jury jurisprudence
the the economists say for instance once
you try to set it come about come up
with laws you can't because the
jurisprudence still doesn't have the
concepts that will then produce the laws
concepts of you know about autonomy
responsibilities that become new our new
concepts are needed another example is
ethics in the long term we want the
machines to be very convivial with us
and but we don't still don't know enough
about our own ethics and so we need more
research into the psychology of ethics
sociology of ethics and so on but in in
dialogue with our other colleagues from
the academia because they need to to see
what kind of scenarios were seeing
coming into the into the into the future
and the same goes for engineer I think I
want to make one more comment just to
mention the social social contract yes
absolutely
yeah and I think there is a very
interesting question that unfortunately
we will not be able to resolve in a
hundred 20 seconds which is who are
these publics that are bringing into the
room and how can they possibly be
representative of the entire planet you
know I bet that's a real I mentioned the
population of the planet in the next
that's right yeah yeah yeah who's
representing all those feature people's
Stewart final question or comment ok so
I apologize if the panel already dressed
as I arrived a little bit late but the
there is one law which is not domain
specific so in California it's illegal
now at since January 1st I believe for
an AI program to impersonate a human
being without self declaration if you
already discussed that I know we did not
but I mean it seems like as an example
the first step I've talked to hundreds
of people about this not a single person
has come up with any serious objection
and I think it's something that you
could quickly get past so so when the
right wing wants to pass legislation
they had this organization called Alec
which rights laws specific for each of
the 50 state legislatures and gets them
passed this seems like a law that we
could get passed very easily I can't
imagine anyone standing up there and say
yes AI systems should be allowed Mafra
should be allowed to impersonate people
and if they do object then we'll have an
AI impersonate them and see how much
they like that real great reputation
would hate to see something happen to it
I think that's right and so maybe a
final comment is
you know I do think that this community
is missing a ground game right that like
we there is no Alec compact like the
analog for people concerned about these
issues and that actually does severely
limit your ability to actually shape
realities on the ground
so I'll we are out of time aren't we
Athenee or we no one really knows what's
our happiness yes and with that thank
you very much thank you so much for this
wonderful panel
[Music]